she said yes lamar odom reveals he's  engaged the former basketball star took  to Instagram to reveal his engagement to  his girlfriend of three months life  coach Sabrina Parr Odom announced the  news on Instagram writing introducing my  new fiance soon-to-be mrs. Parr Odom she  the one power showed up her ring on her  own social media writing I said yes  Odom who was previously married to Khloe  Kardashian just last month took to  Instagram to open up about his  commitment to his girlfriend and  expressed how he's over talking about  his exes writing quote this is the most  serious and committed relationship I've  ever been in with a woman  adding I'm tired of people asking me  questions about my exes based on old  interviews and old comments I was young  wasn't sober and going through a lot all  of that is different now I'm at where I  want to be at  [Music]